he was just like such a great guy like
I'm not I'm not even sugarcoating it it
was like I had nothing I only worked for
him two weeks you've known him
practically 20 something years he's such
a good person he's so thoughtful you
know he really supported me through that
process and we were definitely Partners
in the evolution of that Journey he
inspires me even now I went off and I'm
do I did this um Star Wars show and I
and after having just worked with Keanu
again like in resurrections I would feel
him kind of like his energy my time with
him
um his words how I know him what I've
seen about him what were with me through
the process because it was I was on my
own you know I didn't have my my bestie
over there you know like